le bilan est simple on ya cru jusqu'au
bout ils y sont allés
on y était pour gagner on l'a gagné en
fait pour nous c'est une grande victoire
nos enfants le niveau ça c'est clair bon
maintenant les filles
ben ils ont fait que des premières
places ils ont super gérer quoi c'est
impressionnant même petit minimes qui
marche fort icade est un qui l'année
prochaine va prendre du volume encore
donc pour les filles je pense que c'est
vraiment top
maintenant les garçons nano et qui a
supermarchés les deux premières
compétitions à pissos et à comment la
voeckler où il fait 4 et 5
donc il a vraiment bien marché dès le
départ
après on avait la chapelle basse mer où
c'était une course à étapes sur deux
jours donc le samedi le dimanche donc le
samedi et juan cano screen donc prend le
maillot jaune et c'était eux c'était une
première pour ce qu'il faisait au point
donc il connaissait pas trop donc
deuxième jour il fait 2e au sprint
c'était un
s'il appelle une course de côte c'est
dix fois on tournait dix fois sur le
même circuit mais il y avait une belle
bosse de 14% et à chaque fois les gamins
pas s'effacer la bosse en premier quoi
donc ils ont bloqué et le maillot jaune
et comment le maillot à pois et
malheureusement il s'est loupé dans la
dernière étape où en fin de compte il
croyait que ça passe suffisait mais
celui qui était 2e a fini premier donc
perd son maillot jaune mais garde le
maillot à pois
alors l'expérience moment tigre est en
fait de ces compétitions et de ce
championnat en fait ce sera une belle
expérience déjà pour les jeunes parce
que cela leur a permis en fait de
découvrir autre chose que les causes de
chez nous et de voir les différents
niveaux
est-ce qu'on est performant mais moi
j'estime que oui parce que les jeunes
ont su mouiller le maillot
ils ont brillé sur toutes les
compétitions donc on peut dire qu'ils
sont performants
moi maintenant c'est sûr qu'il faudra
appuyer dessus mais on peut dire on a un
certain niveau gagnant